I'd like to start today's video with a question we'll history rate George W dot
Bush as the worst president ever,
at least half of Americans thought so a decade ago during his presidency,
his approval ratings absolutely sought after the worst terrorist attack ever on
American soil.
Then they bottomed out near the end of his term as the conflict in the Middle
East,
trudged on a president's son with all of the privilege and the welds.
He was a party boy in his youth and he was never expected to go into politics.
So what made him follow in his father's footsteps and well,
what is the uptake today?
So in the video today,
we're gonna dive into the life of America's 43rd President George W Bush.
George Walker Bush was the first of six children born to you,
George H,
w Bush,
and Barbara Pierce Bush on July the sixth,
19,
46 in new haven,
Connecticut.
The Busch family,
they were well off.
There's was a prominent northeastern banking family and later a political dennis
state at the time of bushes birth.
His father,
George senior was an undergraduate students at Yale University.
Immediately after graduating in 1948,
George senior broke with family tradition and to move to as young families or
the boom towns of west Texas to try his luck in oil bus,
but that first apartment in Odessa,
the bushes at to share a bathroom with neighboring prostitutes.
In 1950 though the family settled in Midland,
Texas once referred to as the headquarters of the independent doyle man at the
time,
215 oil companies had offices that Bush senior would eventually earn a fortune
in the oil business,
making millions.
By the time he was only 40 years old,
the first family home in Midlands was in a development nicknamed Easter egg row
for its tiny colorful houses.
As the Bush family grew,
however,
they needed more space,
so they moved to a larger home on Ohio Avenue in 1951.
Georgie as he was often calls,
was only five years old at the time.
Today,
bushes,
Charles or time is listed on the national register of historic places and it's
open to the public six days a week.
Bush enjoyed an idyllic baby boom of childhood.
Growing up in West Texas,
the neighborhood,
it was safe.
It was full of a young families.
He played baseball idolizing the Great Willie mays and developed friendships
that remained throughout his entire life.
The Sam Houston elementary school.
It was not far from his house.
In 1953,
though tragedy struck the busch family were in three year old pauline robin was
diagnosed with a strange disease.
Neither Barbara rolled George senior had heard of before and that disease was
leukemia.
Despite their best efforts taking how far from home for treatments in New York
Sloan Kettering Cancer Center,
Robin died just seven months after her diagnosis.
George Jr was seven and did not known his sister's grave condition.
After a death,
his parents picked him up from school in the big green oldsmobile.
He recalled years later being positive that he saw his sister in the backseat
upon seeing how he was excited and he ran up to the car to see her.
When his parents broke the news,
he understood that she was gone and it changed their lives forever.
Some say the loss of Robin was the impetus for the deep bonds that George Jr
runs Barbara Forms.
They both spent a great deal of time together after her death.
Eventually the busch family added three more children to the clan,
including Neil in 1955,
Marvin in 1956 and another daughter Dorothy in 1959.
That same year with George senior success in the oil business.
The bushes relocated to Houston
in 1960.
The 14 year old Bush was sent away to attend the exclusive all boys boarding
school.
Phillips Academy in Andover,
Massachusetts.
Yeah.
He lived in the shadow of his more successful luminous father for a fun loving
tax and Phillips.
It was a drastic change.
The curriculum was rigorous.
The environments was ultra structured and it was cold Bush.
It was pretty envious of his buddies back.
Hey,
they were able to do things like take their girlfriends house on a Friday night
date,
so with no social life to speak of Bush,
he played sports instead.
Now academics,
they did not come easily for Bush.
He received a zero on his first race and assignments and not wanting to fail.
Bush spent many nights Phillips Academy after curfew,
studying by the light that seeped under his door.
He developed a love of American history during his high school years and said
later that he would bloom where he was planted in his adult life.
Bush acknowledged receiving a first rate education at Philips in 1964 when it
was time to go off to college.
Bush chose his fathers and his grandfather's Alma Mater,
Yale University.
During his freshman year,
his father decided to run for Texas senates and called upon his son for help.
Bush Jr worked on the campaign doing what he could from Connecticut's the elder
Bush.
Well,
he lost the campaign,
but it did prove to be a valuable first time learning experience for George Jr.
While at yale bush had a bit of a reputation for being a good time skype.
He excelled socially like he alWays has,
and he's struggled with his studies.
He was a c students.
He also wanted to play baseball,
but quicklY found out that rugby actually suited him Better.
He played the position of fullback in his first year,
bush joins the fraternity,
delta kappa epsilon or d,
k e,
and eventually he became president.
It was in his junior year that he was tapped for introduction into yale's
premier secret society,
skull and bones.
He was the third bush together with his father and his grandfather to be
indicted.
Now,
conspiracy theories have attempted to link this secret group to the cia,
the illuminati,
even the nazis,
and even to this day,
bush himself,
he remains tight lipped about his involvement as a bondsman.
Either way,
bush graduated with a bachelor of arts degree yale in 1968.
This was the very same year that martin luther king jr and jfk were
assassinated,
and as the war in Vietnam was raging
in may of 19,
68,
bush was commissioned into the Texas national guard.
After two years of training and active duty service,
he was assigned to houston flying combat [inaudible] with the 147th
reconnaissance wing out of the ellington field joint reserve base.
Now,
during this presidential campaign in 2004,
critics of bush included democratic national committee chairman terry mcauliffe
accused of receiving preferential treatments while in the service of being
absent without leave awol from 1972 to 1973 following the control of the
department of defense released all records related to bushes,
taxes,
and national guard service in june of 2005.
According to his released records,
bush never flew in the air national guard.
After april of 1972,
his pilot's license had been revoked for failure to undergo the mandatory
physical examination.
In 1972,
busH was living in montgomery,
Alabama and is working on the us senate campaign of republican winton and loud
while in Alabama,
he drilled with you 187 fighter wing of the national guard.
Bush was honorably discharged on november the 21st 1974.
Now in 1973,
bush entered harvard business school and graduated with an mba in 1975.
Then soon after,
in 1977,
he began his industry career in Texas oil,
establishing our bus do energy with a number of other private investors.
Operations began the following year in 1978.
Now,
bush was not as successful in the oil business and his father and he sold our
bas do in 1984 to spectrum seven,
another Texas gas exploration fan.
He remains the ceo of this business under the terms of the sale in 1986 spectrum
seven merged with hok and energy corporation where bush held a seat on the board
of directors and retains an annual consulting contract.
Then sometime later in 1988,
which was working on his father's bit to become the next president of the United
States.
It was at this point that he learned his father's friends and fellow oil man at
each child's was selling the Texas rangers baseball franchise.
Not wanting to see this opportunity slip by bush organized a syndicate to
punches a controlling interest in the team.
As a report it $89,000,000.
Bush became the general manager of this team even though his initial investment
was only half a million dollars.
Indeed,
bush even took out a loan to pay for his shaft.
It was in 1990 that bush sold is hawkin stock to pay the balance of the loan off
that had taken out to purchase the ranges two months after the south.
However,
harkened released its quarterly numbers showing a larger than expected loss.
Unsurprisingly,
insider trading allegations erupted and the sale of bushes stock was
investigated by the us securities and exchange commission who ultimately found
no wrong doing.
In 1977,
bush was invited to a barbecue at his friend's house in Texas.
The only other guests was a woman bush had never met,
even though she was from midland to bush,
was enamored with the beautiful teacher and librarian,
dora,
lane,
welch,
and the two fell in love almost instantly.
It was a short while wind romance before they will add three months later on
november the fifth,
19,
77.
The couple have settled in midlands and in 1981,
the couple had fraternal twin daughters,
jenna and Barbara Bush credits his wife laura,
with bringing his own life into water as a young man.
He was aimless with periods of unemployment.
He drank too much and he really enjoyed going out as he refers to you as his
nomadic periods.
One embarrassing episode came back to Haunt him years later on the campaign
trail in 2000 or the age of 30 while on vacation in Maine at the family's summer
residence.
He was arrested for drunk driving,
which kept them out of private until the story broke in the news media.
When asked about it,
he responded.
I often times said that years ago I made some mistakes.
I occasionally drank too mucH and his ideas on that night.
I regret that it happens,
but it did.
I've learned my lesson.
So after his marriage do Laura Bush,
he joins the united methodist church and became a born again christian.
The day after his 40th birthday on july the sixth,
19,
86,
bush gave up drinking alcohol for good
bush decided to run for the governor of Texas as a republican after his father
failed to win the presidential reelection in 1992 as manager for the Texas
rangers,
bush had earned a reputation as a savvy businessman and so he was well liked in
his home.
State,
has campaigned against the democrats on richard's focused on welfare and tort
reform,
reducing crime and improving education.
The richards camp was sure that bush would make a gaful,
lose his temper on the campaign trail,
but he never did.
It was a close race and it was a contentious one bush.
Then it will be won the election with 53 percent of the vote and was sworn in as
the 46th governor of Texas in 1995,
he became the first child of a us president to be elected as a state governor in
1998.
He was reelected with 69 percent of the vote and became the first governor in
Texas history to be elected to serve two consecutive four year terms as governor
bush was left with a budget surplus which used to push a $2,000,000,000 tax cut
plan to reduce property taxes and increase funding for education reform.
The tax cut was the largest in Texas history and to pay for it,
he saw to the federal government's approval to privatized social services to
other nodes.
Will pieces of legislation is signed into law included the lowering of the age
at which juveniles could be tried as adults in criminal cases and the
requirements of electric retailers to buy a portion of energy from renewable
sources.
Eventually,
Texas became the largest producer of wind power to electricity in the United
States.
In his second son,
bush promoted faith based organizations and proclaims june the 10th,
2000 jesus day in Texas.
This was a day in which he urged all texans do onto the goal to serve those in
need.
Now,
a criticism of his time in office was the fact that under his leadership,
Texas executed 152 prisoners at the time.
It was more than any other taxes governor,
but overall bush had a reputation for working well across the aisle in a non
confrontational way,
and this earned him a great deal of respect throughout this first time and after
his successful been easy reelection.
Many were speculating whether bush would make a bid for the white house.
On june the 14th of 1999,
bush formerly announced his candidacy for the republican presidential
nomination.
These stages I'm running because our country must be prosperous,
but prosperity must have a purpose.
The purpose is of prosperity is to make sure the american dream and touches
every willing heart.
The purpose of prosperity is to leave no one out to leave,
no one behind.
I'm running because my party must match a conservative minds with a
compassionate heart and I'm running to win during the early parts of the 2000
presidential campaign.
Bush enjoyed a double digit lead in the polls over his opponents and vice
president al gore junior.
As the election approached,
the gap narrowed and gore bush won the popular vote by 543,895 votes.
With the deciding votes hanging on Florida,
the race was determined to be too close to call by major news networks.
After first proclaiming gore,
tHe winner,
the margin was so close that it spurred a recount in some counties.
As lawsuits made their way through the courts,
the final interaction count was bush with 271 and gore with 266 due this day or
an e five presidents have lost the popular vote and won the election.
Bush was sworn in as america's 43rd president on january the 20th,
2001,
but the second diamond history,
they son of a former president had made it to the white house.
The first,
by the way,
that was john quincy adams.
He was elected in 18,
24.
His father was John Adams,
the second president ever,
but she's new administration.
It was focused on compassionate conservatism.
This embraced excellence in education,
tax relief and volunteerism among faith based and community organizations.
It wasn't long before his focus drastically shifted as he was faced with the
greatest challenge of any president since abraham lincoln on the morning of
september the 11th,
2001 19 men trained by al-qaida,
carried out a coordinated attack on the United States hijacking for large
passenger airplanes with the intention of crashing them into major landmarks.
Three of the four planes hit their targets,
the north and south towers,
the twin towers of the world trade center and the pentagon.
In arlington,
Virginia.
The fourth plane crashed into a field and rural Pennsylvania in a single day.
These deliberate acts of mass murder kills nearly 3000 people for 100 of which
were first responders.
As these attacks were happening,
president Bush sat in a classroom at the end of each book at elementary school
in sarasota county,
Florida with children.
He was reading the pet goat,
white house chief of staff,
andrew card whispered in his ear,
informing him a second plane hit the world trade center.
What president bush did next was possibly one of the most controversial
decisions of his presidency.
He stayed in the classroom for seven more minutes following along with the
students reading before excusing himself.
It was brief since gave a short press conference while at the school before
being taken to a secure location in order to board air force one Michael Moore
in this film fahrenheit,
nine slash 11 was highly critical of bushes.
Seven minutes of inaction in the classroom,
more claims that it indicated the bush was indecisive.
On the other hand,
his defenders made the case for keeping the children come,
saying that it was bushes most important duty at the time from the white house.
On the evening of nine slash 11,
he spoke to americans with resolve to fight terrorism and stand together as a
nation.
America and our friends and allies joined with all those who want peace and
security in the world,
and we stand together to win the war against terrorism.
Tonight I ask for your prayers for all those who grieve,
for the children whose words have been shattered for all whose sense of safety
and security has been threatened and I pray they will be comforted by a power
greater than any of us spoken through the ages in psalm 23,
even though I walk through the valley of the shaDow of death,
I fear no evil for you are with me.
In response to the terrorist attacKs of nine slash 11,
bush declared a war on terrorism and formed a new cabinet level department of
homeland security.
These ends american forces into Afghanistan to break up the taliban and
Extremist group under osama bin laden that trains financed and exported
terrorist teams.
The taliban was disrupted but been laws and was not found until much later
following the attacks.
President bush also recast the nation's intelligence gathering and analysis
services and ordered reform of military forces in order to meet a new enemy.
At the same time as doing all of this,
he had other political promises to keep and delivered a major tax cut.
Now,
bushes,
most controversial act was the invasion of Iraq.
On the belief that iraqi president,
saddam hussein post a grave threat to the United States by possessing weapons of
mass destruction,
the weapons,
though they will never found saddam was captured that many american servicemen
and friendlier rocky's lost their lives during the conflict in a state of the
union address in 2005 bush plan that the us would help the iraqi people
establish a fully democratic governments bringing hope to the region and lift a
threat from the lives of future generations.
Bush,
he left office with an abysmal 33 percent approval rating,
but despite this bush political advisor,
carl rove said that bush has an inner confidence that what he did was right
after he left Washington dc.
Bush and hIs wife laura returned to midlands and promptly took up residence at
the priory chapel ranch in crawford,
Texas.
Then they also bought a house in dallas and became part of the community.
Unlike some former presidents,
bush seems to enjoy the rest and relaxation of being out of office.
He golfs,
has taken up painting,
attracting national attention at attendance,
Texas rangers,
baseball games.
He's also heavily involved in the local community.
He occasionally,
he gives speeches and was very involved in the George W.
Bush institute that he established at southern methodist university.
He said once,
I think parts of having a fulfilling life is to be challenged.
I'm challenged on the golf course.
I'm challenged to stay fit and I'm challenged by my paintings.
I am happy,
so I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every monday and every thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every monday and thursday.
Won't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.